human rights are universal but they're
not being realized for the children
because the children are vulnerable it's
easy to sell them to marry them off to
sentence them to a life of labor adults
are not particularly responsible in all
situations and they abuse children every
way we can think of so for us to rise up
as a community and say the rights of the
child need to be protected they need to
be established it's it's past time that
we stand up and do this
people are selfish and children are
victims over and over again and this is
why I mean although almost every nation
signed on to ratify the the rights of
the child in fact in practice this is
not being experienced by millions and
millions of children around the world
and it's really incumbent upon us as
adults to impress upon other adults the
need to respect children and their
rights and I think a lot of it has to do
is simply re teaching adults that you
know just because a child is is small
and vulnerable you can you can do
anything to that child but it also
requires something stronger and that
means every government and all but two
governments did sign on to it must stand
by each and every child and we know
that's not happening
but we must open our eyes a little wider
open our hearts and become more active
in shepherding the rights of the child
right down to the level where it
actually influences every family every
adult and finally every child
the first place I went to with UNICEF
was Nigeria then Angola then Darfur and
r4 and r4 then I I've traveled now
eleven times to the Darfur region and
eastern Chad not always with UNICEF more
often on my own twice to the Central
African Republic once to Haiti with
UNICEF there are situations in some of
the countries I've mentioned where we as
UNICEF we can't say certain things just
because we need access to the children
so I step aside and just as as an
individual mia farrow
I can say whatever I want and I do and
it's really since mine my first trip to
Darfur in 2004 and then again in 2006
that I witnessed things that I could
just no longer be silent about and it
changed my life I don't even I don't
want to do movies anymore I don't want
to act anymore the things I used to be
I'm not they gave me the opportunity to
work with UNICEF and now I just want to
do this full-time
at least in democracies we can influence
our governments there was a late Senator
Paul Simon an American senator now dead
who said that if just 100 people had
written in or contacted their their
leadership during the Rwandan genocide
that our government would have
intervened
whatever you feel about that
it does play squarely on our shoulders
gives us a real sense of our
responsibility as as individuals
now I come from a generation that
brought an end to a war because we
considered it to be unjust and this was
the Vietnam War and it was individuals
one by one taking to the streets writing
to the government protesting on on
campuses March peaceful protests for the
most part we expressed our our view to
our government and I believe that you
know if like the late Senator Paul Simon
said just a hundred people from every
district and by that means every
congressional district er every Senator
in every state out of all the millions
of just a hundred right in
we represent millions so it gives us you
know a sense of power and I think
responsibility to be the one that's
heard many countries they don't care
what you say it's much harder to have
laws passed but we can work in subtle
ways within our communities certainly as
a mother of seven sons of fourteen
children but seven sons my obligation to
bring my children up in a way that we
will resolve our conflicts peacefully we
can all do that
as as parents as citizens and within our
communities to help young people resolve
their conflicts peacefully and and
pursue an avenue other than violence
when we try to resolve just locally
within our communities whatever conflict
might arise
no I don't even know where to begin I've
seen so many child soldiers that
couldn't have been more than 10 or 11
years old in uniform and with guns I've
seen little children raped and and as if
that wasn't enough by many men and as if
that wasn't enough their legs were
pounded into pulp afterward you know we
I come away from some of these strips
with huge existential questions about
who we are as human beings and how we
have to be more alert and aware of our
own components as human beings we have
the capacity to do wonderful things and
help each other and we have the capacity
to do terrible things to each other and
to acknowledge that we have that those
components on them and take
responsibility for them I mean this is
huge and I feel that you know as a
parent a single parent of my own
children that you know if every parent
and every human being just says you know
yes you know the enemy is also me and I
accept that I can do terrible things I
am capable of doing terrible things and
I'm also capable of doing immense good
in this world and helping others and
it's it's a question of decision and
weeding out those components that are
less worthy to be the person we need to
be